P: Oh, It's so boring without any friends.
*end my suffering*
P: But wait a minute..
P: JAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA-
J: TOPPO'DAMORNIN'TOYA'LLLADDIES!
P: Oh My Goooood.
P: You're here.
J: I'm here.
J: Let's do some shiiiit.
J: Why did I agree to this?
J: You were just like,
J: "HEY"
J: "Show up in my house,"
J: "Hey, you wanna record a video?"
J: "Sure!"
J: "Let's go..."
J: "POODIEPIE."
J: "LE'S DO DIS"
P: Don't make my impression.
P: God dammit.
P: Hey, let's do this.
J: Bros...
J: Bros..
P: TOPPADAMORNIN'
J: No..
P: That's not even how you do it. *EpicFail*
J: No, it's not..
P: Catch. *Throws a water bottle to Jack*
J: Oh, Okay..
P: I challenge you...
P: Jacksepticeye...
P: To A Bottleflip Challenge
P: We have a foot cam.
P: Three, two, one go.
J: OHHH!
*( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)EAR_RAPE( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
J: Haha, we fuckin' suck
P: This is gonna be greaat!
P: Okay, but..
P: Here's the thing,
P: There's a twist.
J: Ok...
P: Der's a twist!
P: Der is a twist everybody
J: Der's a twist everybody!
P: If you don't..........do the bottle flip first,
P: You have to pick a reddit 50/50.
J: Oh no-hoho!
P: So 50/50 50/50.
P: More like a 80/20 but still them 50/50.
J: Oh nooo.
P: And you guys at home, you get to watch anyway.
P: Ok let's go down.
P: Let's go down to camera number two.
J: Ok wait.
P: Ok.
P: Camera number two.
P: Here we go.
J: Phew.
J: *Grunts*
J: OH HAHA.
IAMTHEONEDON'TWEIGHATON(▀̿Ĺ̯▀̿ ̿)
J: SECOND ATTEMPT!
J: SECOND TRY!!
J: I MEAN- I MEAN FIRST TRY!
P: Sponsored by Eviaaaaan!!!
P: God dammit.
P: Camera number one.
J: Hello.
P: This is so fucking weird.
P: Okay.
J: Are u just gonna pick at random? You're gonna have to..
P: I go- I'm going from the top.
J: Okay, what-
P: Fetus on ground after
P: Crash with pregnant woman.
P: I don't believe that's a thing.
J: Okay or-
J: Or a photo of quintuplets in the uterus.
P: I don't wanna see either of them!  (dafuq Jack?)
J: Yeah, why am I still looking at this???
P: You can look away Jack.
J: Okay.
P: Okay.
J: I'll judge- I'll judge by your reaction.
P: Here I go.
P: Oh that's nice. (kill me ples ;-;)
P: GOT EM!!! GOT EM!!
P: That's disgusting!
P: Get that shit away!
P: What the..
J: What is wrong with you?
*dafuq*
J: "Ah it's pretty good."
P: I got you.
P: Ano-
P: Back to camera number two.
J: Oh Jesus Christ
J: Okay, go!
P: Ooh.
J: Fuck.
P: Fuck.
IAMTHEONE(▀̿Ĺ̯▀̿ ̿)
J: UHRGH.
P: I think I have too much water in mine.
J: Fuck.
P: No no,
P: Hey, HEY! *DA'S CHEATIN*
P: Hey.
J: Fuuck.
J: YA-HAHAHA
P: Wait wait.
P: I got one-
P: I got one- I got a chance.
J: Come on, come on...
P: NahH!
J: You're terrible at bottleflips!
P: Apparently I am, yeah.
J: Do you even meme broʕ•ᴥ•ʔ
P: Shut the fuck up *ples jek*
P: AH NOT AGAIN!
P: JESUS.
P: Ah my god!
P: AH MARKIPLIER!!
J: AH it's Mark!
J: Why is he there?
P: I was looking at his videos( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
J: Ooooooo.
P: Okay- alright, alright.
P: It's time for my punishment.
P: Train runs over a parked car.
P: That's pretty cool.
J: I mean its a- It's a car.
P: Man demonstrates some very impressive green screen action.
P: Oh is this a video of- of me?
*nope(ಥ_ಥ)*
P: Oh no I got the car one.
J: Is it a video?
P: Yeah it's a jif (or gif o whatever....stfu)
P: Ohhh!
P: Thats awesome!
P: Don't look yet.
P: Ok look- ok, look at this.
P: Hahahaha.
P: WUUUUT!?
P: Tshaha
J: WHAT!?
J: That was awesome!!!
P: Hahaha.
J: It's so seamless!
P: It looks so real.
P: That was good.
P: That was really good.
J: Man I like this game!
J: Thank you Felix.
P: Heey, you're welcome.
P: The uterus, the train...(all the good stuff)
J: The human body...
P: BACK TO CAMERA ONE!
J: CAMERA ONE!!
*wait for it*
▄︻̷̿┻̿═━一
P: OHH!
P: FIRST TRY EVER!
J: Ok.
P: YES!
P: FINALLY! I knew I could do it!
J: Okay bros!
P: Don't look Danny Devito.
J: ...Here we go we're gonna do 50/50.
J: Ok...
J: Hamster eats a tiny burrito or man eats a tiny hamster.
J: Why? Why would you do that?
P: What the fuck.
J: Oh, oh..
P: EWW EWWWW!
P: EWWWW!
J: What-
J: NO!
P: WHAT THE FUCK!
P: Take it away!
P: WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
J: Oh that actually made me gag...
P: Really?
J: Oh my god, why?
J: Why would you do that?
*I'm sorry you had to see that, kid*
P: Why did you do this?
J: I thought it was gonna be like oh he just puts the hamster in his mouth...
P: He chewed
J: He chewed and the hamster like popped.
P: Asians what's wrong with you? (WTF Markiplier)
J: Oh no my poor little... my poor little Irish...
J: NO THERE IT IS AGAIN!
P: He's got that blue hair (Edgy AF)
P: Aw what the fuck it-  auggh....
J: See you almost got sick as well.
P: What the fuck is this in my mouth?
J: Is it a hamster?
P: I don't know.
J: CAMERA ONE!
P: CAMERA-
P: I don't have the technique down yet.
J: Yeah I don't- I don't get it.
P: Ohhh.
J: OOhhh.
P: Auughh.
J: Yeah- yes!
P: I-I still hope.
J: I AMTHEONEDON'TWEIGHATON
̿̿ ̿̿ ̿̿ ̿̿ ̿'̿'\̵͇̿̿\з= ( ▀ ͜͞ʖ▀) =ε/̵͇̿̿/’̿’̿ ̿ ̿̿ ̿̿ ̿̿
J: Camera one!
P: Okay camera one.
P: Ok, oh it's my turn, FUCK!
P: I dont wanna.
P: Puppy digs a hole.
J: Or a dude with a hole in his face.
J: Click- click on it Felix
P: Please, be the puppy.
P: Please, the puppy.
P: I need... the puppy.
P: THAT IS NOT A PUPPY! *words of a man who's seen everything*
J: Does he have a hole in his face?
P: Oh what the fuck is he alive?
J: That's not a dude with a hole in his face,
J: That's a dude with a half a face...
*nice one......lol*
Both: CAMERA ONE!
*EPIC*
P: OH!
*MORE FUCKENN' EARRAPE*
*STILL RAPIN' DEM EARZ*
*my ears came(◉_◉)*
J: That doesn't count!
P: OH! MY! GOD! That fucking counts!
P: ALLL THE WAAAYYYYYY (to fuckin' victory town)
J: Ohoho, for fuck's sake.
P: Yeeees!
J: Bull running accidents or tree frog croaking.
J: Slippy!
J: Don't pay attention you're the best frog.
J: That's frogs!
P: Aawww.
*wut*
*da*
*FUCK*
P: See they do that, but they don't shit afterwards.
J: Why did you get-
J: Why didn't you get a tree frog then?
J: Instead of a hamburger.
P: Don't make fun of my fucking frog.
Slippy: Oh my god. It's my friends.
S: Put me down, ASSHOLE!!!
J: Is he gonna shit?
J: Don't- don't shit.
J: No don't- don't touch him.
J: Plug up his butt hole.
J: He's reacting, tree frogs the natural enemy of hamburgers.
P: Final one jack...
P: This is it....
P: You think you better than me?
J: Yeah.
J: I've won more of them.
P: This is all or nothing.
J: Okay we'll mix up the bottles.
J: I don't know which is which...
P: Whoever wins this one...
P: Welcome everybody to the yearly bottle-flip championship tournament.
J: Sweden versus Ireland.
P: Sweden versus Ireland.
P: Ok Sweden starts.
P: Never mind.
P: Fuck.
J: Ahh it's so close every time.
P: NO!
J: This bottle is fucked.
P: I AM THE ONE...
💣💥🔥
P: NO!
J: YEAH!
P: Okay it continues.
P: It continues.
P: OOOOOH!
Both: *Screaming*
P: God dammit.
P: Oooooooooaaaaaaahhhhhhh!
P: NOOOOOOOOO!
J: We couldn't do it at all earlier.
P: Come on.
*Shitty Timelapse*
J: Not the one
P: I AM THE ONE!
P: Come on Sweden Sweden Sweden!
P: The pressure is so much-
P: NO!
*BOOM BITCH*
P: WHAT THE FU-HU-HUCK.
P: This is ridiculous.
J: YES!
P: For Sweden.
J: *No, please no*
P: YES!
J: NO!
J: That was the highest one too.
P: What the fuck?
P:This finale is killing me.
P: Oh.
J: Oooooooohhhhhhh.
P: This is it. This. Is. It.
*Pleas don't be on of those sad endings*
(Whyyyyyyy)*RIP peace*
P: Yes!
*SWEDISH BATTLECRY*
P: I am the best bottle flipper!
P: I'm sorry *Please don't cry Jack😥*
P: Yes!
P: Slammin'!
P: Jacksepticeye.
J: You scared the shit out of me.
P: Well now we know who the best bottle flipper is.
P: Now as punishment... I'm gonna let you watch....
P: My least favourite video in the whole world.
*some weird-ass gigglin'*
P: Here you go, enjoy!
J: Ok.
J: Bye.
*fuckin' ad*
J: He's so loud!
J: What's wrong with him?
P: Alright well, thank you Jack for doing the bottle flip challenge.
J: No problem
P: No let's not call it that...
J: Yeah.
P: Check out Jack if you for some reason dont know who he is, I'll link him in the description-
J: Yeah, it's not like I'm a fucking meme here already.
P: Wait that's a person?
J: There's a play button with my name on it there!
P: Can I just get to see you with that, there you go...
P: As the loser of the bottleflip challenge you get this golden play button.
J: I don't want this, this is tainted!
P: It's yours now!
P: Leave a like if you enjoy and I'll see you bros.. brofist.
J: TOPPO'DAMORNINNNN!!!!!